l'obscurité est lourde certains
d'entre nous portent plus que d'autres
parce que nous sommes assez forts pour supporter le
poids
en faisant tout cela de travers
nous avons survécu à tout pour ce qui
continue à se battre et à s'entre-tuer
nous verrons quand il s'agira de moi
c'est juste une question de temps  avant de
faire le même appel mon dieu non
tout le monde
se prépare
c'est mon honneur ce soir de présenter
quelqu'un qui n'a pas besoin d'être présenté le
gouverneur du commonwealth mme pamela
milton
grâce aux sacrifices de mon père nous sommes
tous ici
brique par brique et bloc par bloc
nous '  reconstituer le monde
tel qu'il était
[Musique]
cet endroit est comme une ville d'avant
où les gens qui ne peuvent pas s'intégrer sont chassés
tu te souviens
oui je fais
[Applaudissements]
certain que tout le monde sait exactement qui
et ce que tu es
[Applaudissements]
préparez-vous
on va refaire le monde